bonjour maire de bourlet Valence ville
de 20000 habitants 4e ville du
département de la Drome aujourd'hui je
fais le constat après d'une année de
mandat de maire de l'inertie et de la
lenteur des services d'une collectivité
qui a été détenu par la gauche depuis
toujours combien de fois j'entends dire
par mes services bien écoutez madame le
Maire ce n'est pas possible parce que
nous avons tout essayé aujourd'hui nous
les républicains nous avons la volonté
d'aller sur le terrain comme le fait
Nicolas Sarkozi nous ne sommes pas des
élus à rester dans notre tour d'ivoire
et nous avons élaboré bien évidemment
des actions envers notre population moi
j'ai deux exemples par rapport à ma vie
je n'ai pas hésité à passer 5h dans une
caravane pour déloger des gens du voyage
qui occupé illicitement un terrain
communal depuis des années je n'ai pas
hésité non
aller dans les quti sensibl merci
beaucoup
pour pour aller à la rencontre seul de
ces jeunes qui sont en rupture c'est une
approche qui fait grincer des dents bien
évidemment par les fonctionnaires
territoriaux qui refuse d'appliquer ma
politique et face à ce refus
d'obéissance nous sommes impuissants et
il est important de faire des véritables
réforme concernant le statut de la
fonction publique et la fin de l'emploi
à garantie à
moi je
souhaite je suis heureuse de faire pare
du comité des ma présidé
par pour que nous les Mair nous fions
entendre la voix de NS administr Eneu
braoup